this one will unfold fairly quickly
adapt first simplest use of acceleration
our expression for X double dot when
it's not a function of displacement
bladder function of velocity now do you
remember it's the product of two little
bits and pieces what's this result over
here not that you need romo cuts on the
reference sheet there's no reason why
you can't it's v DV MDA it's very good
okay so this is what i doona working
with Thanks it and you can see the
reason you go to use this I mean not
just because I said acceleration is the
function of velocity but you look
carefully at the acceleration expression
yeah right Obie's very time to in terms
I to know displacement 20 is where to so
this is the only tool we have left in my
experience better student and after
thought a few times one of the most
confusing things is students who look at
the expression like this and pretty much
ignore what variability terms of you do
that to your own peril because you can't
really work with it unless you choose
but very much this is with respect to
velocity what they want us to find is
just this simple question where does the
particle rest where's the particle risk
so let's begin you've gotten the
acceleration expression and we're going
to use this to unpack it's not working
with it so I'm just going to simply
substitute here V DV on DX is equal to
and he's is the expression so what are
all our different forms of acceleration
right let's actually just refer their
take them that long you're up this one
you've got DVR dt you've got d squared
on dt squared you've got this one and
then you've got half B squared on DX
okay so what you want to do is have a
look at what variable that's a deep what
very well have you been given
acceleration in terms of okay so for
example you can't really deal with
either of things unless you have a cell
as a function of time all right does
that make sense you have to integrate
with the streets of time to use Iovine
to use this one use one acceleration as
a function of X right because you're
going to integrate with respect to X
this right here I have all in v's and
there's the V right there even though
you think oh but there's a non DX there
doesn't that mean I have to integrate
with respect to X but there's also v up
here so I can turn it upside down and
then off I go okay which is in fact what
I'm about to do so you can see there's
an extra factor of V on both sides which
I really wanted to be there so i'm going
to divide through okay Lenzi then once
you've got this you want to get towards
something which cadets where which is
the displacement function and how
quickly is Vivek which is when you know
it's at rest okay so what am I going to
do to this line I'm gonna have to take
the reciprocal because all this is in
terms of these carnies you vary with
respect to X so I need to get the wizard
affects you on the bottom right since
dinner DX on DVDs ok so you have a look
at that and now you're ready to
integrate with respect to X what's that
going to be this is this is going to be
a log function right it's going to be a
lot of function now if this is f then we
would usually expect f dash to be if you
didn't see you didn't see that numerator
what would you expect def touch to be it
expect it to be too but it's in fact
negative 1 okay so therefore it's too
small and it's got a negative on it so
i'm going to write x equals negative up
half I believe that's the factor that
I'm off by log of FX on FV rather want
us to it now this is not a definite
integral and there are no more integrals
left so I better include a constant ok
so far so good done integration how am I
going to resolve is constant what am I
going to use
i have i've got to be able to use these
conditions in some way so which one's am
I going to use together because this is
a constant of some kind I should have
said that the question does the V is
some speed some starting speed and I'm
sorry if the origin so I'm gonna pop
both of those who feel so when 0 the
police you just be careful by the way if
you're like me when you write use in a
hurry or v's in a hurry they look like
you used to just be cautious I've got a
substitute here which gives me this
let's see negative a half log of what
was to you bosses the constant equals 0
so therefore the clots that is just a
half log opposed to you so far so good I
can bring that back because I noticed
that this is positive and this has a
negative in front of it advice I'll put
this guy out of the front so i'm going
to say x equal to a half more dog take
away that to be with a point on it at
this point ya know yes it looks okay do
we want the city i can simplify here car
tire I'm going to pause and ask whether
i need to simplify because remember what
the question is asking dude is fine
where the particle isn't rest so what
does that mean when the velocity is 0
I'm going to be solving for x okay so
what I have a look at this where's v
it's just there when it becomes 0 this
is take away a half log one log 1 is 0
okay so you know what even though I
could simplify by taking a factor of a
half hour you see some log blows in here
and combined into a single log 1 i'm not
even going to bother right because i'm
just going to say x equals all that
disappears i should say when v equals 0
right all of this is just going to
become
a half 1 plus 2 u minus behalf no one
which you just taught me the value of
okay so therefore tunne whatever that
happens to be right meters per second I
of course this is a displacement so by
the way I'm you're dead interpret oh
this is X meters to write or above or in
the positive direction baby I hadn't
given you any other anchors as to what
directions to talk about happy mix it's
just asking like the very often why you
wrote mind with the particle progress
yeah and from that time on with you
careful via yes but you're happy camper
yeah that's a really good question what
can we do that by doing that take care
because there's let's let's contemplate
for a second that's kind of a [ __ ] if I
suppose gave you something like this
yeah okay so we usually say or you
better not divided by X right you bet
not divided by X why not because you
lose a solution right you lose a
solution when you say that namely you
lose x equals zero right it's not like X
can equal 0 I mean clearly again that's
why it's a problem to divide through ok
so if I'm dividing through here all I do
is remember hey when you did this you
lost the solutions you just don't forget
don't forget when you come back you can
still say you can still pop it in in
fact that's exactly what you would do if
you are go through any working and you
delivered at a solution where it's like
more complicated this all we have to do
is say well are there solutions that I
might have missed for example when you
say this as soon as you introduce that
you miss solution so what do you do to
overcome that you just test which is
kind of exactly what I did so it's all
right